one of the tightest races the race for
Nevada attorney general the incumbent
Democrat Aaron Ford joined us last week
today we are joined by Republican
Challenger Seagal Chatta and thank you
so much for joining us on 8 news now
thank you so much for having me you
wanted to talk about something that was
maybe a misunderstanding or a
misrepresentation in terms of your views
on the 2020 election you have been
called an election denier in my research
I did not find a source of you denying
the election what say you on this topic
right Ryan I mean here's the thing my
first interview was here at Channel 8
where I clarified very very simply
that you know the 2020 election unless I
saw that there was evidence that there
was a stolen election unless it was
produced and you know sufficient judges
ruled on it then uh then there's there's
no such thing to deny and you feel
President Biden is a legitimate
president absolutely well absolutely I
mean he's living in the White House and
you know and I mean yes he is yeah he's
a few years into living in the white
house now now in a more serious topic
you sent a text to a former friend about
A.G Ford you said he should be and I
quote hung from an effing crane
I have to just ask off the top I
understand it was a private text to a
friend but why would you write that
those words
um
the bottled water bottled waterfall
that's okay okay
we'll take care of that okay but why
would you write those words about A.G
Ford so here's here's the short of it
this was a conversation that was
discussing corruption and government
corruption and Hamas
and the comparison that I had made was
prepared him to a liter of Hamas because
I do believe that he is a corrupt AG
everything that we have seen the past at
least two years
um even up to four years have
demonstrated that we are dealing with a
very corrupt attorney general can you
understand though even with your
different political views than him that
um
will that comment in America about an
African-American man even if it's not
how you intended it could be deemed
racist can you understand how people
would hear it and see it that way
if it was used in a context describing
somebody in a racist manner but I was
not you know to say that I use it in a
racist manner is absolutely absurd look
I'm a yemenite Jew okay we're the blacks
of the Middle East there's no question
about it all right I'm not going to say
that this was racist this has nothing to
do with race this had to do with
corruption and comparing him to a leader
of Hamas which in my opinion is a very
corrupt militant terrorist organization
A.G Ford said he does not consider you
racist but he did consider the text
racist when we interviewed him do you
feel that you need to reach out and
apologize and explain that to him
or his team
um that that I'm not a racist I know I'm
not a racist but but that he felt that
that text was racist do you feel you owe
him an apology I don't I don't
I've had nothing to do with race it had
to do with corruption and I think that
as somebody that I believe is corrupt
while listen we don't hang people from
cranes in the United States there's no
question about it okay but corrupt
people do go to jail and
um you know I don't know that they get
executed in the U.S but that was in
comparison to a leader of Hamas and
that's what they do to traders in the
Middle East
we have a lot of political issues to
discuss but I want to clear up something
else that many considered offensive use
of the word [ __ ] in a tweet the
trans transgender Community considers
that a quote slur do you feel that that
word is okay to be used I know that it
you mentioned it's used in movies and
books but since that Community considers
it offensive why not use the word that
that Community does not deem offensive
for example instead of [ __ ]
transgender would you consider a more
sensitive path would you consider granny
less offensive than grandmother this is
the this is the community's view not my
view I'm asking you I'm just asking you
to comment for them what I I can't
comment for them I can't comment for
them I mean you know like I said the
word [ __ ] used in it's it's used in
Hollywood it's it's part of the American
culture this isn't a word that is taboo
um it's still being used so you know if
if that the use of that word is
offensive to a group
um absolutely I would apologize to that
group but at the same time I think in
the grand scheme of things
the change needs to come from on a much
bigger scale so let's about Ben
Hollywood from using the word [ __ ]
let's been American literature from
using the word [ __ ] just like any
other word that has I guess coming in
out of circulation you know we don't
call Native Americans Indians and I
don't think that you see that work being
used anymore because it's so offensive
but yet the word [ __ ] is still used a
lot
I want to give you a chance to talk on
those two issues we're going to get to
some political issues it would be 236
habitual offenders petty larceny for
example you said you want stricter
penalties please be specific as to what
you would want to change okay so ab-236
we know that that's the Criminal Justice
Reform Bill it increased habitual
offenders the definition of a habitual
offender from a two-time felon to a
five-time tough felon I find that very
disturbing okay our streets are
obviously now being flooded with
habitual offenders
um you know there's there's a reason why
the law is written the way it is to
address habitual offenders
um so the way I look at it is I would
reduce that back to two-time felon for
it to be considered a habitual offender
numerical amount as well the 1400 back
down in terms of it's actually 1200. are
you talking about Petty Larson yeah 1200
what do you want to knock it back down
to so you know here's the thing when I
came out of law school it was 350 okay I
would like to see it if not reduced to
650 at I'm sorry if not reduced to 350
at least to 660. let's keep moving civil
criminal law you've practiced for over
two decades the church closures during
covid-19 was something you were really
fighting against talk about what you did
specifically with Calvary Chapel versus
so Calvary Chapel Lone Mountain Versus
sisalak was a church closure case
um it was an
excuse me can I just grab water
absolutely take your time okay sorry and
again just for those that are watching
we're referencing the lawsuit Calvary
Chapel uh versus select this is
involving Church closures during the
coronavirus pandemic and again further
explanation by you when you're ready in
terms of that fight yeah so
yeah sir case was truly a violation of
the free exercise clause now I'll tell
you as somebody of the Jewish faith okay
um the the closure of religious worship
didn't specifically affect my Orthodox
Community because Jews you know you only
need 10 people for a million but it did
affect churches and it did affect other
places of worship okay and Calvary
chapelone Mountain was is a church that
has a capacity of 700 people
when people were going through coven
okay many times if you're religious you
you search to a higher power for
explanation right
um you know you don't know this is a
pandemic you don't know what's going on
and religious worship is very important
in this country
um to many people so I I decided to take
on this case right take on the governor
take on the governor I felt it wrong I
felt that no matter what kind of
pandemic no matter what kind of
situation Wars have been waged around
the world and places of worship have
stayed open and again we are getting
shorter on time so I want to move move
ahead churches were open about 10 days
before Christmas as I remember reporting
on it two more topics quick quicker
answer here access to covid vaccines for
seniors what would what was your effort
there talk about what you did a little
bit of a shorter answer so when when the
coveted vaccines were being rolled out
there was an issue with with the speed
of the rollout okay I felt that uh the
most vulnerable population in the state
was not getting access to the vaccines
as they should have because they had the
highest comorbidities
um for covid
um and so I filed a lawsuit against the
governor and Aaron Ford to first of all
speed up the rollout which was being
done between two and three thousand
people a day we sped it up and within 45
days we were up to 15 000 vaccines and
the governor reduced the age from 75 to
65. less than a minute left uh we we in
my research I look into this I see you
have called the AG a quote convicted
Criminal in my research I found no
evidence to support that the larceny
case from his days in Texas in college
in his early 20s was dismissed
so can you explain why you're calling
A.G Ford a convicted criminal well many
times what happened this is it is a
standard in criminal justice you could
be convicted but the minute that you pay
the restitution or the minute you you uh
complete your courses whether it's
Victim Impact Panel and DUI cases or
anger management classes in domestic
violence those cases will be dismissed
I'm not the attorney you are but then
how would he be a convicted criminal
when it was dismissed because it was
dismissed based on a payment of
restitution
we appreciate your time thank you so
much a lot of topics thank you so much